усе що нас оточує щодня звідкись
привезене і найчастіше привезене здалеку
усе що ми купуємо у крамницях потрапило
туди завдяки вантажівкам фури життєво
важливі для торгівлі але вони на жаль
все ще дуже шкідливі для довкілля
зменшити викиди від вантажівок
Можливо але для цього їх необхідно
переобладнати двигунами які працювали б
на струмі або на
водні двигуни з яким пальним виграють
перегони
чи у майбутньому знадобляться і ті і ті
фури перевозять великі вантажі на довгі
відстані чи реалістично це з
акумуляторами було багато упереджень
щодо акумуляторних технологій говорили
що батареї занадто дорогі занадто важкі
занадто великі
вважалося що фури з важкими
акумуляторами можуть перевозити менше
вантажів до того ж можуть застрягнути в
дорозі крім того для експедиторів час це
гроші а вантажівки які годинами стоять
поки заряджаються акумулятори для них не
варіант тому виробники зробили ставку на
паливні елементи які за допомогою водню
і кисню виробляють достатньо
електроенергії для живлення вантажівки з
викидів в Атмос ру лише тепло і Вода для
виробництва водню як палива потрібно
багато енергії але зусилля того варті
загалом воднева вантажівка протягом
свого життєвого циклу спричиняє на 33%
менше викидів CO2 ніж дизельна фура
звичайно результати були б ще кращими
якби використовувався зелений водень
тобто той який отримують з
альтернативних джерел енергії Але такого
водню виробляється все ще надто
мало заправка водним функціонує
Приблизно так само як і
дизелем паливні елементи спершу
виглядали як єдина добра альтернатива
дизелю але акумуляторні технології
нездоганяють упередження що батареї
дорогі і важкі більше не
актуальні технології за останні роки
досягли неймовірного
прогресу акумулятори За відносно
короткий час стали значно дешевшими їхня
Так звана енергетична щільність також
покращилася це означає що з батареєю
того ж розміру вантажівка тепер може
проїхати набагато довше наразі ж також
розробляються новітні системи так званої
турбозарядки які дозволяють суттєво
економити час приблизно 15 хвилин
замість кількох годин тоді водії фур
зможуть заряджати свої вантажівки під
час обов'язкових перерв що просунуло цю
технологію вперед гроші виділені на
дослідження адже більшість урядів і
виробників роблять ставку на
акумуляторні двигуни для
автомобілів кращі і водночас дешевші
батареї були розроблені завдяки світовій
автомобільній промисловості з іншого
боку є лише відносно невелика кількість
гравців які працюють над розробкою
водневих паливних елементів а також
зберіганням і доставкою водню вантажівки
з акумуляторним живленням також мають
перевагу в тому що вони дешевші в
експлуатації ніж водневі вантажівки для
того щоб паливний елемент працював
водень спершу треба отримати за
допомогою струму потім його
транспортують заправки і закачують в
паливний елемент який потім знову стає
струмом однак близько 60% енергії
втрачається в дорозі для роботи
електровантажівок з акумулятором навпаки
потрібна тільки зарядка втрачається лише
близько 20% струму тож вантажівки з
акумуляторним живленням мають нижчі
експлуатаційні витрати однак вони
дорожчі ніж водневі зразки якщо скласти
всі витрати на транспортний засіб
електровантажівки з акумуляторами мають
непогані показники до того ж витрати
продовжують знижуватися фури на струмі
можуть стати дешевшими за дизельні ще до
2030 року якщо заряджати їх сумішю
струму з викопних та відновлювальних
джерел енергії то це дозволить заощадити
близько
63% викидів якщо використовувати лише
відновлювальні джерела енергії то
економія становить
92%. то що перегони акумуляторих і
водневих паливних елементів вже
закінчилися навантажівки з акумуляторним
живленням нині припадає менш як 1%
світових продажів але в Європі за
прогнозами вони почнуть домінувати на
ринку до 2050 року і такі світові гравці
на авторинку як daйler і Volvo які
загалом роблять ставку на водень
додатково розробляють також вантажівки з
акумуляторним живленням ці виробники
дотримуються гібридного підходу оскільки
вважають що перевезення вкрай важких
вантажів на багато тисяч кілометрів буде
неможливим у найближчому майбутньому за
допомогою вантажівок з акумуляторним
живленням коли вирішальною є вага а не
простір для транспортування то більше
підійдуть водневі
вантажівки але такі випадки радше
рідкість кажуть
критики для цих особливих випадків
доведеться побудувати всю інфраструктуру
включаючи мережу водневих заправних
станцій Отже питання у тому як зробити
так щоб вантажівки з акумуляторами були
в змозі перевозити дуже важкі вантажі на
дуже великі відстані одне з можливих
рішень просто замінити розряджену
батарею замість того щоб заряджати її
протягом тривалого часу але це
вимагатиме спільних зусиль всієї галузі
і узгодження стандартів А як щодо
інфраструктури незалежно від типу
екологічних вантажівок інфраструктуру
необхідно суттєво розширити водневі
заправки поки що зустрічаються рідко у
багатьох регіонах Європи їх взагалі
немає стовпчикові зарядні станції
призначені для приватних електрокарів
але зарядні станції високої потужності
необхідні для екологічних вантажівок
майже повністю відсутні у ЄС цю проблему
Можна було б вирішити змінивши
законодавство зараз з'являються великі
компанії які кажуть що збираються
інвестувати в інфраструктуру тому що
бачать у цьому сенс політика могла б
створити безпечний простір для
інвесторів
таким же чином необхідно заохотити
масове виробництво фур без шкідливих
викидів тому що досі ще не виробляється
достатньо електровантажівок щоб
експедитори могли переобладнати свої
автопарки Ось чому ЄС хоче переглянути
свої стандарти щодо викидів вихлекислого
газу для вантажівок до 2040 року нові
фури мають викидати на 90% менше CO2
щодо водневих вантажівок є ще одна
проблема
[музика]
ціна нам потрібно комерціалізувати
виробництво водню наразі коли говорити
про екологічно чистий водень ми
виробляємо його у дуже малих масштабах і
Це проста річ коли ви розширюєте
виробництво ви можете знизити
витрати Тож як швидко фури ставатимуть
екологічними залежить від багатьох
чинників наскільки маленькими і
доступними у ціні будуть батареї в
майбутньому Як швидко їх можна буде
заряджати і чи буде колись достатньо
зеленого водню наразі електровантажівки
ефективніше живляться від акумуляторів а
не від паливних елементів але обидві
технології служать одній меті зробити
економіку і зокрема торгівлю кліматично
нейтральними тобто з мінімальними
викидами вуглецю Але до цього ще довгий
[музика]
шлях